what's up guys Greg Knuckles here with
string theory comm and today we asked
ourselves the question which are better
full-body or split routines actually we
don't first we ask ourselves the
question is that even the right question
we should be asking is that a question
that's likely to give us a useful answer
and I would argue no the reason why is
that your response to training isn't
static so there is there is no single
best training routine for everyone in
the world or even just for you at all
points in time because as you train your
body it adapts in in two different ways
one the stressor provokes an adaptation
that is positive it makes you bigger
stronger etc the stuff you want to
happen but also because it's a stress or
your your body becomes more efficient
and handling that same stressor in the
future because remember getting bigger
and stronger is primarily a protective
response because when you train you
disrupt homeostasis and so your body
makes your muscles bigger and stronger
so they'll they'll be more capable of
handling that stressor in the future but
also other protective mechanisms are in
play that makes that particular type of
stressor disrupt homeostasis less than
it used to so when you when you're
training a particular way and you
plateau the well the number one thing
you should do well you can do two
different things you can either increase
the type of stressor or you can increase
the magnitude of the stressor so
increasing the magnitude of the
stressors is primarily just ramping up
your training volume you know adding
weight adding sets adding reps etc but
you can't do that forever obviously and
so at some point you're going to need to
change some of those other variables
and this this leads into the question of
whether you're better off doing
full-body or split routines now in
general you're probably better off
spending most of your time or a larger
percentage of your time doing full-body
routines not necessarily every muscle
group every day but including both some
upper and lower body lifts because
that's that's necessarily well it's not
necessarily but it's going to give you
opportunities to increase how frequently
you're training each muscle in each lift
and in general training something more
frequently to a point is a good thing to
do a few different things are in play
muscle protein synthesis isn't elevated
for too terribly long after a workout 36
to 48 hours for a fairly new lifter
tends to be somewhere closer to 12 to 24
hours for a more experienced lifters so
if you're only training a lift once a
week muscle protein synthesis isn't
elevated for for that large of a
fraction of time you get more
opportunities to practice the lifts
you're training to master them a few
other things but those are the two
Biggie's so in general higher training
frequencies tend to be better and so you
know you could train squats and bench
say both three times a week if you're
training six days a week but if you're
training three four days a week then
generally a full body routine is going
to allow for higher frequency but once
your body adapts to that level of
frequency then you have to ask yourself
a question
you know first can I add more volume per
session and you can do that for a while
but when it gets to the point that you
can't do that then you're probably
better off dialing back your frequency
because even though in general it
doesn't carry those those same
particular advantages the advantage that
it does have is if you're only say
squatting once or twice a week you know
you may be able to do 8 10 12 sets of
squats and those workouts whereas you
probably wouldn't want to do that same
thing four or five days a week so the
per session volume can be
higher and so if you've gotten to the
point where the volume you can handle
for a lift so I'll just use squats as an
example so if you've gotten to the point
where you're training the squat three
four times a week and you've raised the
volume as high as you possibly can for
those three four sessions and your squat
still isn't improving then what you can
do is you can dial back the frequency
and that's going to allow you to push
the per session volume higher and so
obviously since since you weren't
adapting since you weren't getting
stronger then whatever you were doing in
those three four days a week apparently
wasn't enough to sufficiently disrupt
homeostasis to cause a beneficial
adaptive response
so with dialing back the frequency you
can increase the volume per session and
then even though you're not getting as
many sessions disrupting homeostasis
causing those beneficial effects the
sessions that you are getting in do have
high enough volume to sufficiently
disrupt homeostasis help you get a
bigger and stronger then once you've
done that for a while your muscles are
you know you're going to plateau
eventually and your muscles have what
they've adapted to as a higher per
session volume but a lower frequency so
then you can remain frequency back up
keep getting bigger and stronger so like
I said at the start of the video the
question itself isn't a particularly
good question if the question you asked
was what what on average has more
benefits higher or lower frequency
training or full or full body or split
training you know there's an answer to
that question it tends to be full body
higher frequency per lift training but
even though even though it has some
advantages that doesn't necessarily mean
it's better for everyone one because
it's not going to be some people's
preferences - it's not going to fit in
some people's schedules but then even if
you know it does fit your preference it
does fit in your schedule that still
doesn't mean that it is necessarily
better at all points in time it may be
better for you the majority of the time
but once once you've been doing it for a
while once you've adapted to it once you
hit a plateau then almost by
definition it's no longer the best thing
for you because you've just reached a
point that continuing to train in that
same manner no longer gives you the
ability to disrupt homeostasis enough to
tell your muscles to keep getting bigger
and stronger so so that's the basic idea
a paper that I would really recommend
everyone watching this video read it's
called periodization paradigms in the
21st century evidence led our tradition
driven it's by strength coach and
periodization theorist John Kiley
I very strongly recommended one of the
things that that he very rightly points
out is that most studies comparing
different periodization schemes or
training programs the the biggest
takeaway from most of them is just when
you put people on a training program
that is significantly different from
what they were doing before they tend to
get bigger and stronger so you know with
with a lot of the training programs that
are higher frequency programs in the
studies that actually went through and
described the subjects training
backgrounds most of them had lower
frequency training backgrounds so the
way the studies were set up it was
basically with one group training
essentially how they'd been training
before very similarly and another group
doing something that was very different
so the question you have to ask yourself
is whether it was necessarily the
variables in the study itself that
caused the beneficial adaptations or
just the fact that the program was
different from what they've been doing
before and Kylee he doesn't he doesn't
come down on the totally like nihilistic
extreme that nothing is better or worse
than anything else but he does he does
rightly point out that just just simply
novelty getting people to do stuff they
haven't been doing previously seems to
be one of the biggest factors so to wrap
up this video in general for most people
most of the time higher frequency
full-body training
tends to be better it it tends to have
some advantages that lower frequency
split type training doesn't but at the
same time just because it may be better
for most people most of the time and it
may be better for you right now that
doesn't necessarily mean that it's
better for you say three four months
from now if you plateau with that level
of training frequency then at that point
you probably would be better off dialing
it back using a split routine and if
you've been using a split routine for a
while and you've plateaued
you'd probably benefit from ramping your
training volume up so um yep short
answer it's not really the question you
should be asking in the first place so I
hope you enjoyed this video and if you
did please like and subscribe and hey
this is this is two videos in the same
week not not four months between these
last two so I'll see you in the next
video and yeah maybe maybe
it will also be within the next week
I'll just see all right bye